und jetzt das heute journal
mit heinz wolf und marietta slomka guten
abend bundesinnenminister horst seehofer
ist zurück von seiner türkei und
griechenland reise beiden ländern müsse
bei der bewältigung der flüchtlingskrise
geholfen werden mahnte er
auch gestern abend hier im heute journal
zuvor hatte er schon italien angeboten
ein viertel der aus seenot geretteten
flüchtlinge in deutschland aufzunehmen
wenige hundert menschen seien das nur
rechnete er vor
und sagt in dem zusammenhang auch es sei
unglaublich dass er sich für die rettung
ertrinkender menschen rechtfertigen
müsse das klang allerdings schon sehr
anders als der seehofer dennoch vor gut
einem jahr davor warnte mit
präzedenzfällen flucht anreize zu setzen
in der csu aber auch bei der
schwesterpartei cdu kommt da nicht jeder
mit patricia wiedemeier berichtet es
werden wieder mehr flüchtlinge die über
das mittelmeer nach europa kommen 25
prozent der geretteten bootsflüchtlinge
könne deutschland aufnehmen wenn andere
eu staaten freiwillig mitmachen das
hatte innenminister seehofer
vorgeschlagen und mit einigen wenigen
ländern so vereinbart
in den letzten zwei tagen reiste er
zudem in die türkei und nach
griechenland war dort für eine
gemeinsame europäische asylpolitik
gleichzeitig sagte er den eu-staaten mit
außengrenzen hilfe zu sonst sei eine
flüchtlingswelle größer als 2015 zu
erwarten wenn wir ihnen nicht helfen das
möchte ich der bevölkerung in
deutschland sagen dann ist es nur eine
frage der zeit bis waren diese
flüchtlinge auch in deutschland sind für
wirbel sorgt nun seehofers vorschlag mit
der 25 prozent quote die rückendeckung
der regierung soll er zwar dafür haben
nicht jedoch die der eigenen fraktion
der vorsitzende brinkhaus reagierte
heute sehr zurückhaltend zitat es stelle
sich die frage welches signal man sendet
wenn man pauschal 25 prozent der
geretteten flüchtlinge aufnehmen will
wir dürfen schlepperorganisationen nicht
ermutigen mehr zu machen das war eine
initiative des innenministers nicht der
cdu/csu-bundestagsfraktion es ist vor
allem eine unionsinterne debatte über
eine quote die viele nur unter
bedingungen akzeptieren
für uns ist aber ganz entscheidend dass
dadurch keine neuen pull faktoren und
anreize für migration gesetzt werden und
deshalb haben wir als unions fraktion
auch klar zum ausdruck gebracht dass wir
aus diesem mechanismus wieder aussteigen
wenn die ankunfts zahlen in europa
steigen
skepsis auch bei der opposition ich
denke der weg den seehofer einschlägt
ist der falsche er sendet ein signal für
mehr migration aufnahme garantien sind
anreizsysteme zu kommen wir brauchen in
europa breite mehrheiten für die
beschlüsse wenn herr seehofer aber nicht
mal seinen eigenen fraktionsvorsitzenden
überzeugt dann bin ich skeptisch ob ihm
dies auch mit den chefs anderer staaten
gelingen wird es ist wichtig dass der
innenminister jetzt auf europäischer
ebene klar macht dass es wirklich um
eine gemeinsame europäische lösung geht
um solidarität und dass deutschland auch
aus den vergangenen jahren gelernt hat
dass die vereinbarung wieder ausgesetzt
werden kann
sollte die anzahl der schlepper boote
stark ansteigen oder falsche anreize
gesendet werden ließ seehofer heute noch
schnell über sein sprecher verbreiten
dennoch die diskussion über die
flüchtlingspolitik sie ist neu entbrannt
und wird wohl weitergehen wie sehr es in
der bevölkerung iraks brodelt wird der
breiten weltöffentlichkeit wohl erst
seit einigen tagen bewusst seitdem dort
täglich demonstriert wird
die regierung hat zunächst versucht die
proteste brutal niederzuschlagen polizei
und staatssicherheit schreckten auch
nicht davor zurück scharf zu schießen
nach offiziellen angaben wurden über 90
menschen getötet mehr als 4000 verletzt
inzwischen erklärte sich das parlament
bereit über die forderungen der
demonstranten zu debattieren
es sind überwiegend junge männer die auf
die straße gehen um gegen die
misswirtschaft im land zu protestieren
dara hassanzadeh berichtet
sie sind unbewaffnet und rennen um ihr
leben
es ist der fünfte tag der proteste in
bagdad und das fallen wieder schüsse
heute morgen wurde die ausgangssperre
aufgehoben ein versucht die situation zu
beruhigen die kontrolle zurück zu
erlangen ministerpräsident allmacht die
zeigte sich schon gestern
gesprächsbereit
wir haben eure forderungen verstanden
wir wissen dass ihr ein ende der
korruption verlangt dass ihr arbeit
braucht reformen wünscht die das land
voranbringen es sind berechtigte
forderungen und eure sorgen sind uns zu
sorgen am abend ein treffen zwischen
demonstranten und regierungsmitgliedern
ergebnislos zeitgleich gehen die
sicherheitskräfte weiter massiv gegen
die meist friedlichen demonstranten vor
keiner von ihnen glaubt noch an diese
regierung
sie halten nichts als die flagge in
ihren händen
sie fordern nur grundlegende rechte ein
arbeit und ein funktionierender staat
jeder vierte dieser jungen menschen ist
arbeitslos ohne perspektive der start
wird von korruption aus gehört der bau
etat für krankenhäuser wurde in diesem
jahr komplett veruntreut
das trinkwasser ist verschmutzt strom
gibt es im irak nur stundenweise
und das in einem so rohstoffreichen land
doch die öl milliarden versickern
schlimmer noch sie scheinen die
ungehemmte korruption im land noch
weiter zu befeuern
die gründe für die proteste liegen in
der schlechten wirtschaftslage in den
miserablen lebensumständen und vor allem
in der allumfassenden korruption man
spricht von 450 milliarden dollar
die seit 2003 bis heute durch die
korruption verschwunden sind
neben der korruption lastet noch der
wiederaufbau auf dem irak ruinen trümmer
hat der kampf gegen den as hinterlassen
und die pro-iranische milizen im land
die an der seite der irakischen armee
kämpften offiziell unterstehen sie der
regierung in bagdad doch gesteuert
werden sie aus teheran
sie verfügen über militärische macht und
haben großen ökonomischen einfluss
sie führen ihre angelegenheiten
unabhängig durch sie agieren als
eigenständige politische kraft als ein
militärischer staat im staat
auch dagegen richtet sich die wut der
jungen iraker es könnte sein dass sie
bald nicht nur gegen ihre eigene
regierung kämpfen müssen sondern auch
gegen den großen nachbarn iran die
nachrichten von heinz wolf beginnen
jetzt mit den ermittlungen in paris hat
der messerangriff eines mannes im
polizeihauptquartier und paris könnte
einen terrorhintergrund gehabt haben die
ermittler gaben heute unter anderem
bekannt dass der täter anhänger einer
radikalen interpretation des islams
gewesen sein und kontakt zu
mutmasslichen salafisten gehabt habe der
mann hatte am donnerstag vier seiner
kollegen im polizeihauptquartier
erstochen bevor er selbst erschossen
wurde
bei den ermittlungen zu einem
amtsenthebungsverfahren gegen
us-präsident trump erhöhen die
demokraten mit ihrer mehrheit im
repräsentantenhaus den druck sie werfen
dem weißen haus vor es habe angeforderte
dokumente zur ukraine affäre
bisland nicht freiwillig herausgegeben
deshalb greife man nun zum instrument
der sap nach einer gerichtlich
durchsetzbaren aufforderung
trump kritisierte die ermittlungen gegen
ihn erneut scharf und nannte sie einen
betrug am amerikanischen volk
unterhändler der usa und nordkoreas
haben einen ersten versuch die direkten
gespräche zwischen beiden seiten wieder
in gang zu bringen unterschiedlich
bewertet die nordkoreanische seite
zeigte sich nach dem treffen in
stockholm enttäuscht und brach die
verhandlungen laut medienberichten ab
aus washington hieß es dagegen die
gespräche seien gut gewesen und man habe
die schwedische einladung für eine
weitere runde in zwei wochen angenommen
in hongkong hat die regierung ein
vermummungsverbot verhängt trotzdem
gingen heute wieder hunderte
demonstranten meist mit masken im
gesicht auf die straße sie zogen durch
das einkaufsviertel und protestierten
gegen die regierung und den einfluss
pekings aus sorge vor ausschreitungen
wurde der u bahn verkehr vorläufig
eingestellt auch viele geschäfte blieben
geschlossen
in portugal wird morgen gewählt
ein land das auch wirklich
hoffnungsvolle weise zeigt dass man aus
einem tal der tränen auch wieder
herauskommen kann
die internationale finanzkrise hatte das
überschuldete land schwer getroffen
es musste unter den europäischen
rettungsschirm und damit auch auf einen
harten sparkurs
heute steht portugal ganz anders dar
staatsverschuldung ist immer noch hoch
aber das jährliche haushaltsdefizit
wurde gesenkt jetzt gibt es wieder raum
für mehrausgaben
investoren schätzen die politische
stabilität in portugal die der
ministerpräsident costa trotz
minderheitsregierung hinbekommen hat und
jungen portugiesen kommen zurück die
ganze stimmung hat sich gedreht
thomas weiter berichtet antonio musste
seine wohnung in lissabon räumen ein
investor wandelte sie in eine
ferienwohnung um doch melo hatte glück
im unglück
die stadt hat diese günstigen wohnungen
auf den markt gebracht zuerst 14 später
noch mal 44 und ich habe
glücklicherweise eine bekommen
die regierung will mehr öffentliche
wohnungen anbieten das ziel bezahlbare
mietwohnungen auch für arme menschen
hier macht die stadt lissabon aus einem
ehemaligen bürogebäude wohnungen für
familien eine trendwende
das ist das ende der sparpolitik vor
dieser legislaturperiode wurde kein
einziger euro in das öffentliche angebot
von wohnungen investiert
ministerpräsident antonio costa das ist
vom sparkurs abgerückt den geberländer
verlangt hatten
die hilfen nach der finanzkrise gibt
alle sagten das wäre teufelszeug aber es
hat investoren nicht abgeschreckt
sondern sie haben vertrauen gefasst und
mehr investiert als in der vorigen
legislaturperiode
wir haben 330.000 neue jobs geschaffen
touristen bringen geld ins land nachdem
es anderswo terroranschläge gab die
regierung nutzt den spielraum und senkt
steuern für investoren
lissabon ist sitz zahlreicher start-ups
hier entwickelt auch bmw software nach
der finanzkrise haben junge menschen
portugal verlassen jetzt kehren sie
zurück die arbeitslosenquote halbiert es
gibt derzeit mehr stellen für software
programmierer als programmierer
ich habe mir eine reihe angebote
angeguckt und denke dass ich hier die
besten chancen habe mich in meinem job
weiter zu entwickeln statt schulden
abzubauen setzt die regierung auf
sozialpolitik grasser azevedo verdient
drei euro 35 die stunde als köchin
darum freut sie sich dass die stadt
lissabon jetzt ihre karte für zug und
bus subventioniert statt 73 seit sie 30
euro im monat
zudem hat die regierung den mindestlohn
erhöht die bei vielen niedrigverdienern
fließt das geld zurück in die wirtschaft
ich muss meinen sohn unterstützen und
das geld das ich jetzt spare kann ich
dafür gut gebrauchen er studiert
außerhalb und kommt am wochenende nach
hause
jetzt kann ich ihm die fahrt
portugals regierung macht soziale
politik aber nicht bedingungslos als
fahrer von benzin transportern streikten
setzte die regierung polizisten und
soldaten hinters steuer
die wahl wird zum referendum über die
reformen der linken die regierung macht
politik für die schwächsten und für
investoren ein grund warum das land auch
nach der finanzkrise kein problem mit
rechtspopulisten hat bei der
leichtathletik wm in doha hat es am
abend eine weitere medaille für das
deutsche team gegeben constanze
klosterhalfen hat bronze gewonnen über
die 5000 meter
die 22 jährige kam mit einer zeit von 14
minuten 28 43 ins ziel
weltmeisterin wurde wieder die
kenianerin hellen probieren und jetzt
die lottozahlen dieses samstags lauten
wie immer ohne gewähr
8 17 27 36 47 49 superzahl 5 und weitere
gewinnzahlen finden sie auf lotto punkt
zdf.de und dem zdf text auf seite 55 6
und jetzt noch die wetteraussichten
morgen scheint im nordosten oft die
sonne in der südwesthälfte regnet es zum
teil stark die höchsttemperatur liegt
zwischen 7 grad im westerwald und 16
grad am oberrhein
am montag regnet es nur ganz im süden ab
dienstag ist es überall wechselhaften
zum teil kräftigen regengüssen und dabei
ist es kühl die temperaturen erreichen 8
bis 17 grad
zehnkampf weltmeister niklas call ist
aus doha zurück in mainz und jetzt
gleich im aktuellen sportstudio zu gast
dann wünschen wir hier noch einen
interessanten sport haben bis morgen auf
wiedersehen
[Musik]